prime athlete
who in his elementary soccer team he
scored
half of the goals for that team he
scored one out of two
so please welcome to the stage
dr tom
awesome looks like my screen's up so
yeah thanks so much for the intro there
jared and really excited to be here i've
always wanted to make it to new york r
uh really excited to make it virtually
even though i wish i was eating pizza
right now
so i'm going to be talking about a lot
of different art markdown topics um
really around kind of the strategy of
using
them beyond traditional data products i
really bit hard on this kind of captain
marvel theme so hopefully
you enjoy that uh if not too bad um
it's going to be there throughout and if
you want to follow along with my slides
you can read
the bitly marvel rmd
let's go to the next slide so the reason
why i kind of thought of captain marvel
was a it's a fantastic movie
i really enjoyed it and you should go
watch it um but b
it really covers the idea of like the
heroine's journey and so i'll cover some
of that here without any spoilers
so in act one the story is set up uh you
know carol vander is here
all these different kind of difficulties
she's facing and along with that
here's the tool we're going to be using
our markdown for act two
in the movie uh complications arise
there's some betrayal
and some difficulties and we're gonna be
covering that as some problems with our
markdown to be solved
and then act three our heroine finds
resolution kind of wins the day
and so here's some solutions to those
problems
but as we all know coding itself is not
a linear journey so unlike a traditional
hero or heroines journey which is kind
of a very linear kind of path of going
up and going down
coding is less about this kind of
beginner intermediate expert and more
about
finding and expanding your tool set for
the right job
at the right time so some of these
techniques you might use today some of
them might use down the road but i think
all of them are useful
for for many different stakeholders
the first kind of topic here for our
markdown i'd like to cover is the idea
of an arm arc
on taxonomy so most people think of our
markdown as kind of being one of these
when
in reality it could be all of these
together so the idea of our markdown for
literary programming for data products
for control documents and for templating
and i'll cover all these
throughout today's presentation
so the first one is literate programming
which most people are
probably the most familiar with for our
markdown the goal here
is to capture code text about kind of
what's going on or the analysis
one with comments and output all in a
single document
uh literate programming was initially
kind of coined by donald knuth
and against the idea of mixing natural
language such as english
with snippets of macros or source code
which we can see here on the right
so our markdown is traditionally made up
of a yaml header
which kind of defines the structure of
the document code chunks that execute
arch
r code or other kind of language engines
that are available
in knit r markdown and then text which
can still have
inline code but it's primarily about uh
pros or kind of
talking about what the code is doing or
output and you can intersperse these all
together
kind of taking natural language and
source code and source code natural
language throughout the document
so in addition to being you know just
grid for literary programming and mixing
code uh
our markdown is also the mvp of
reproducibility
so this can mean the minimum viable
product in terms of you have you know
your output
is self-documenting and you have code
that's embedded together
or it's the uh kind of the most valuable
player so it's able to kind of help you
guide to this journey of reproducibility
so our markdown has to run successfully
to save or knit the output so if you do
have errors you can't kind of produce
a faulty output and importantly it's
difficult and human readable and version
control so if you check it into git
or something like that you can parse
through it very easily
in in source and version control
a quick example of what i really enjoy
for using our markdown for literature
programming is covered by both dave
robinson and julia silk who most people
attending this conference are pretty
already familiar with but they do
tidy tuesday's screencasts usually
weekly and they use our markdown to
control
kind of the the programming and code
that they're doing along with
text output or kind of structuring their
document so recommend watching some
other videos or looking at that for
example of literate programming
importantly though when you think of
literary programming we always think of
our markdown but
it's not just for r uh you could
actually run python code natively or
call python from r with reticulate
you could run entire sql chunks to run
native sql code
uh from r or kind of pass it back and
forth you could do front end scripting
with css or javascript or add little
html chunks
and along with that there's a total of
52 possible language engines for things
like bash
rccp stan or many other languages
so this reproducible document with all
sorts of different code chunks
interspersed with text
but enough about their programming so
that that's kind of somewhere where
everyone knows about
data products are also something that
people probably are pretty familiar with
with our markdown
and the idea here is that you're using r
to generate a final output for
consumption
while you still want to be able to
control the source code to kind of make
it reproducible
here you're generating uh you know
graphics or reports or something to
to kind of you know digest some type of
data
so the most common data products uh are
things like reports
presentations entire dashboards
full-blown websites or blogs
books and one of the kind of
underutilized things i think with all of
these data products
is the idea of html widgets um so
for all these i kind of went through
quickly uh again i think people familiar
with that i added links to them
but for html widgets again there's
things like dt
uh reactable plotly crosstalk of many
more that allow you to get somewhat of a
shiny esque experience without having to
have a server backend
and i'll show you a quick example here
so here i have a basic our markdown dock
it's got a yaml header and code chunk to
set up some different libraries i'm
using
we read in a data set from the palmer
penguins data set
assign it as a shared data frame what
this means is it's sharing data across
multiple html widgets which are
basically javascript libraries you can
call from r
so i'm going to use plotly for the
interactive graphic and then reactable
for reactive table
both of which are being fed the same
shared data set
i can then do a code chunk that builds a
little bit of a gui interface
so i got some filters for check boxes
and sliders and then i call
my two my graphic and my table
and what this looks like in practice is
i get my video to load
so this probably looks like shiny to you
in terms of you've got these little
selectors
it's affecting the data both the graphic
and the table are kind of reacting to
uh changes i'm making with you know
changing the sex
changing species or filtering the body
mass but importantly i could literally
like email this to somebody that could
open up and use it i don't have to have
a server back in
i could still use it with shiny and you
can do it that way but
any html output uh can can use
html widgets in this way
so we covered data products we covered
literate programming i went through
those pretty quickly
because again i think a lot of people
that's what they think about for our
markdown
and i'm trying to expand into the idea
of our mark down beyond those things
so the idea of a control document uh is
that your goal here is to modulize data
science tasks or use our markdown to
control your overall
code flow i'll pause here for a second
and talk about somebody else's
presentation
so this uh our markdown driven
development was put together by emily
reuterer
who uh has put a lot of effort into the
idea of like productionizing our
markdown and the use of it
in enterprises so here she has some
modulized chunks that she's using where
she's
sourcing either functions or from an r
package she's got a folder structure
with final reports
data documentation other external files
and ends up with this nice clean
polished markdown that generates and
pulls in data
and performs an analysis i'd really
recommend
checking out her blog post or her video
on the same topic
and i'll be you know proposing a few
ideas that could fit into this kind of
world view of using our markdown
in production setting
so the first idea for using our markdown
as a control document
is the idea of params or parameterized
our markdown
so here we add a special yaml header
so within the animal we have params and
then we're providing
a species argument that's assigned
adelaide
which is one of the penguin species
present in the polymer payments dataset
so i can reference this specific
parameter anywhere within the markdown
dock so i can reference in code
with params uh dollar sign species or in
line with
backtick r params dollar sign species
backtick
so whether using in the code chunk or
inline you can kind of get whatever this
output is and put it into your document
so when i knit this it's going to feed
and add a line replace those
and actually generate a nice report for
me we have data about all these
different penguins
however for the adelaide penguins we
only have 198 and here's a quick
histogram
of those so kind of a basic example but
i wanted to focus here again on the idea
of
uh specific things you're doing to our
markdown rather than these complex
reports
you can also reference external r files
so
for params we're referencing it within a
document what if you had code you're
trying to pull in from elsewhere you
could always source it and that will
pull in a function
but here we can actually pull in entire
code chunks from an external dot
r file so we read a chunk penguins.r
which is seen here on the right and we
can reference these
code chunks by name so this code chunk
is actually empty and i'm just saying
smaller penguins
this code chunk is also empty and i'm
pulling in plot penguins
i'm actually pulling in all the code
that gets executed in here
from these labeled blocks of code from a
dot r file
so i have you know the smaller uh to
define the data set of interest
and this graphic that i'm recreating so
i can recreate my
previous report without having to use
parameters and using external art code
you can also use the idea of external
our markdown documents
so within a parent our markdown document
which is kind of your overall control
structure so this penguins
here is the parent document i can
actually tell it you know use this child
report which is adelaide report.rmd
seen here on the left so over here again
we have an empty code chunk but it's
going to execute
all of the code within this report so
it'll pull in again our smaller
things some pros and text that's
executed with inline code
and then another code chunk to generate
a histogram
so this is pretty fancy i mean you could
have a very lightweight
parent r markdown and have all sorts of
other different dot r files or r d
files that are external and then you can
modularize a report in this way
child documents also have the benefit of
being able to do logic or
conditional statements so again we have
the same child report
but now i've created a logical statement
based around the species select
i'm saying species select is equal to
chin strap which is yet another species
of penguin from the palmer's
penguins data set so here the child
document is only executed
if this specific variable is equal to
adeline
since it doesn't in an equals chin strap
it actually generates a blank report
however if this was equal to chin strap
then it would generate the chin strap
data set
so you can imagine here that you're
sourcing external r files and based up
upon some parameter you're setting from
data basically you read in data and
perform some analysis
it pulls in a specific report and runs
that in line as needed
another one so these have all been the
idea of pulling our code into a parent
document and executing it
kind of doing it the other way is taking
a parent document and creating
child uh reports so blastula emails are
essentially a child report that gets
sent by email
so here i'm creating a penguin's plot
and a penguin's report
so it runs for our markdown but here at
the very bottom
i'm actually generating creating and
sending an email
through our studio connect so here the
input is this penguin email.rmd
which again can use empty code chunks
because i'm referencing existing
shared basically coachups between the
two documents so the pen
and the parent document i have penguin
plot
and i can call that without any code by
just using the same name
and this will generate a full email so
it will generate
this specific html formatted email with
the gdplot inline
in your inbox and you could run this
through our studio connect or through
gmail
or through i think a couple other
different smtp email servers
so again the idea of parent to child
while we're talking about our studio
connect with the idea of control
documents uh our markdown documents can
be scheduled through connect to do all
sorts of really cool things
um so you could do self-service
parameterized markdown for non-tech
users you can imagine you know i as an r
user can do primarizer markdown it's
very powerful
if i give that to someone who doesn't
know what r is they're like
what the heck is this how do i use it so
you could provide them a gui interface
through connect
you'd also schedule etl scripts so
things from sql
web apis or spark for example and run
those out
you also do automated reports with full
logging and history so kind of different
versions of the same report all captured
in one spot
the other part that a lot of my
colleagues use is for long model
training steps so you have like a two
hour training step for this giant random
forest you can run it overnight and have
it save the model out to a database or
to a flat file somewhere
and lastly again you can send blaster
emails conditionally or on a specific
schedule so if this parameter is hit
then send an email to these people
cool so we covered a lot of different
control flows there which is very
exciting
for the last part of the presentation
i'm going to be talking about the idea
of templating
so here people might think of templating
as different themes but i'm actually
talking about
different reports from from the same
code
so here the goal is don't repeat
yourself generate either input templates
or output documents
from code this could be again our other
different languages supported by our
markdown
we talked about parameters and
parameterize our markdown so this is the
same report as previously
but now i can programmatically generate
this report so rather than having to
click knit
in our studio or elsewhere i could go at
the
uh our console and say render this
specific report
with the species equal to gen 2. now
we've generated a brand new report from
the same existing code we could do this
for each of the different
species in the penguins data set
you can also generate many reports all
at once so the idea of running with
parameters plus a for loop or
maybe per map or per walk to generate
multiple reports
so here i'm finding all the unique
different types of pequen species
looping through and generating a report
for each of them with the name
ahead of their report i can do the same
exact thing with per walk
but with a function instead of a for
loop
and now i can see i have three reports
one for adoleigh one for chin strap one
for gen two
all named correctly all generated the
exact same time all with one
kind of execution of code so you can
imagine generating hundreds or thousands
of reports all at once
from a similar code and just changing
the parameters and again
these parameters could be you could have
10 different types of parameters it
doesn't have to be just one
on the other end of the spectrum rather
than generating multiple output files uh
often you may want to generate multiple
repeats within the same document so
rather than generating like copy paste
copy paste different code chunks
you can actually re-execute a code chunk
in a loop or
with math as well so here um i have a
similar report
i'm actually sourcing an external r file
called multi-plot
which is pasting together some text it's
doing some filters and summarization
it generates some raw text about the
data set that i'm using
creates a graphic and then adds some
blank space
importantly for this code chunk i'm
using results equal as is
meaning that whatever the results fit
out uh knitter in our markdown will
actually parse through those
and re-execute the output so
it's kind of weird to think about but
you're basically
knitting this part it executes the code
generates more stuff which is then
executed for the final output
so here rather than creating separate
reports i'm able to create a similar
kind of structured report within a
single document
so adolei and gen 2 and observations and
their flipper link
and then a different graphic for each of
them and again this could be hundreds of
different things all done in line
or just a few as i've shown here
now i was using glue to actually paste
together some things but i think it's
important to differentiate between the
idea of glue and other things like
whisker we think of whisker versus glue
the answer is one versus two so glue
uses these parentheses within a text or
within a character string
and it replaces whatever is inside these
with either our code or a variable name
so there are 32 rows to mt cars data set
we can do something similar with whisker
render
but now we're using two parentheses
rather than a single parenthesis
when i think of glue versus whisker
really the idea is glue is something i'd
use
in line with our code or maybe within a
data frame
whisker is something that i use much
more commonly with raw text files
so for something like the tidy tuesday
project every week i could generate
a pretty standard readme so i could copy
paste this
and kind of change things out which i've
done in the past but
recently i've switched this over to use
tidy tuesday readme which is a function
that actually
pulls in a dot nd file parses through
all of it
puts in the correct date puts in the
correct url and the data set name
and then fills it up with whisker and
then writes it back out as a readme
template i can then post onto github
so for here my whisker output um i can
see the different data and this is what
the output looks like
i have the date uh the year and the week
the name of the data set and all this
was filled programmatically by my
function
that was a readme file so that's
exciting that's raw text but you could
also do this with
our markdown so here i have a template
which is this whisker input which has
double back ticks and a couple
places so species and long pros and
actually you can
fill this raw text file this dot rmd
file
with new things with code so i can
replace this with adolet adoly and this
long
text chunk and then i can start working
with this output document and continue
adding text to it so this is really
powerful because
i am able to reuse the same document and
continue
typing it up rather than having to rely
on doing it all with code
often you generate a report and you need
to add a few things to it so that's
really the power of whisker is you can
write it back out to a
raw rmd file and this is what the
function looks like
it basically just reads it in fills it
pastes the different name out so that
you're not
rewriting over the same document i'm
just adding the different species
the long pros and calling it with
species along pros for my template so a
one-liner which is really powerful
uh useless use template also has the
similar idea
um but you know you're working off kind
of a
use this package which allows you to
provide a template i wrote mine by hand
but you could also use
use this in a similar way
so that's it i covered a lot of
different things you have the power and
i hope that now you can use some of it
and it's interesting to you there's some
follow-up reading here for
a few different blog posts including
mine and again the slides are up at
bitly are marked down
great thank you so much so
before we get to our next speaker yeah
we've been giving away
books this whole time